I cannot believe it is already time to
talk about my best films of 2014 these
are my picks for the 20 best films of
2014 that's right I couldn't Whittle it
down to ten I just couldn't there were
too many good gems that happened this
year that really surprised me that I
didn't feel right not including on this
list and last year when I made my best
of 2013 list I realized that a lot of
people had discovered films they had
never heard of and have thanked me for
the entire year for introducing them to
some of those films so I decided this
year the list should be a little bit
longer so you guys can know about some
of the smaller films that came out this
year that I really loved that I think
flew under the radar and I say this
every year but if you actually examine
the grades that I gave these films
they're not going to be an order from
best to worst and you may find that
strange but that's because a grade is
just sort of a summation of how you felt
about the movie it's not necessarily
gonna make you pick one over the other
some of those movies you may never watch
again even though you gave it a high
grade and some of them you may want to
watch over and over again so you like
them more in that way you know what I
mean
you know what I mean let's talk about
these movies now first off I do have a
few honorable mentions and really fast
one of them is the wind rises directed
by Hayao Miyazaki one of my all-time
favorite directors the reason this movie
is not in my list is because it
technically came out in 2013 and a few
theaters in LA and New York and then it
finally released why this year in
February so to me it came out this year
I don't care I'm sorry it came out this
year such a good movie a very great
animation film and I really hope it's
not Miyazaki's alas but it might be
three of my favorite animated films this
year where the lego movie big hero 6 and
How to Train Your Dragon 2
I loved all of those movies but they
weren't on my list I do however think
they're fantastic and you guys should
definitely check them out a very small
movie not too many people saw was Frank
starring Michael Fassbender or Michael
Fassbender wearing a mask it was really
good it was really charming and not too
many people had the opportunity to see
Frank I would definitely recommend
checking it out also luck starring Tom
Hardy a movie taking place entirely in
one vehicle all about one man struggled
to try to right some wrongs in his life
amazing amazed
performance one of the best performances
of the year Jon Favreau's passion
project chef made me want to eat a lot
of food it was like food porn but it was
also a very heartfelt and heartwarming
movie that I loved also the raid - one
of the best action movies of the year
the only reason is not on my list is
because despite the action being
fantastic I did think that too much of
the story was a little bit pretentious
and they were trying to make it too much
like The Godfather and less like an
action movie and I loved it nonetheless
I thought the action was fantastic I
bought the blu-ray it's just not on my
list
those are my honorable mentions
definitely check those films out but
let's get started with number 20 the
tale of the princess kaguya was Studio
Ghibli's film and quite possibly their
last I really hope it's not but there
have been rumors that it might be their
last film I thought this was a beautiful
animation movie with a very heartfelt
and mature story that resonated with me
deeply and at number 19 we have the
grand Budapest hotel I thought was a
very witty extremely well directed and
fantastically acted movie ray Fiennes
was just oh my gosh not enough people
are talking about his performance he was
so terrific in this movie I loved it
from start to finish it was hilarious it
was so well shot and Jeff Goldblum
knocking it out of the park every time I
see that guy it's like Jeff yeah uh
chaos yes Bob chaos theory yes um I gave
it a cold now my pick for number 18 I
think a lot of people were expecting to
be higher on this list nevertheless
Donna the planet of the apes is
obviously a movie that I loved I bought
it on blu-ray that's saying something
I think it's a very well shot film a
very good science fiction movie very
well acted by Andy Serkis and everyone
really in the movie I do however think
that it's not quite as good as some
people have said I think it's a very
good movie I obviously bought it and the
reason it's not higher on my list is
because I watched it a second time and
to me it felt like it lost a little bit
the second time there were certain
aspects of the film that dragged a
little more than the first time I saw it
I still think it's a great science
fiction movie and considerably better
than Rise of the Planet of the Apes
which I also liked it's just not higher
on my list because it doesn't really
have that rewatch ability that I'd like
it to have coming in at number 17 is a
movie that not enough people saw I
briefly had the chance to see this when
I was in LA I'm so excited to talk about
the guest was like an amalgamation of
drive and then 80s horror combined with
an action movie it was such a strange
movie and all the better for it the
performances were very good the
soundtrack was euphoric I've listened to
it over and over again and it was a lot
better I thought than Adam weingartz
last film you're next I love the style
of the movie I think that it has a very
fun tone and a great reward even movies
coming in at number 16 Keanu Reeves is
back kicking a ton of ass in an awesome
role that I really hope gets a franchise
I love the world-building of John wick I
love the action directing it has one of
my favorite scenes of the entire year in
the nightclub sequence it was like a
10-minute sequence of Keanu Reeves just
being a total badass this movie was
directed very well by veteran stuntmen
who've been working with Keanu Reeves
ever since the matrix i loved it if you
haven't seen John wick it also has a
fantastic soundtrack as well coming in
at number 15 is a film that has been
topping critics list around the world
people are falling in love with this
movie I really liked it
boyhood is a fantastic achievement it's
a twelve-year film in the making you can
actually watch people grow up and grow
older it was a marvelous thing to see
however I can never see myself watching
the film again and that's why it's not
higher on my list
Ethan Hawke was terrific in the movie as
was Patricia Arquette I love the idea of
watching someone grow older and just
small moments in life adding to a hole
and seeing that really it's not
necessarily these huge moments but just
the small moments throughout life that
really impact you and that's why the
film is so emotionally resonating I just
can't really see it having much of a
rewatch ability factor coming in at
number 14 was the return to form for a
very awesome franchise that became
awesome again with x-men Days of Future
past is a movie that righted the wrongs
of the previous films that made
everything better again it was funny it
had great characters it had good emotion
you cared about almost every single
person in this movie and Quicksilver was
awesome and he wasn't an idiot like you
thought he was going to be he was
actually one of the coolest characters
in the entire movie Days of Future past
erase the problems of the previous films
and made this franchise strong again
coming in at number 13 is a much smaller
film that not a lot of people saw and
the ones who did thought it was kind of
terrible I thought it was great under
the skin has a tone throughout the
entire film that just began to infect me
it infected me with this strange feeling
of fear because Scarlett Johansson
played a predator so well and then you
get to see this transformation in her in
which her entire character changes
because of one small moment and I love
this film I thought it was one of the
best directed films of the year it was
very similar to 2001 a Space Odyssey in
the way it felt it had some very scary
moments and the score was so good I mean
like I've listened to it over and over
again I saw in theaters a few times I
felt like it was like a privilege to see
this movie in theaters because it was
such a strange and different movie and
it was so cool to see a movie like this
still being made speaking of smaller
films and that a lot of people saw at
number 12
enemy is directed by denis villeneuve
tried my favorite film 2013 was
prisoners I love that film and I was so
excited to see what his next film was he
actually made this before prisoners it
is by far the most confusing movie I've
ever seen in my life and I made an enemy
explained video after two months of
pondering about this film and tons and
tons of people have thanked me for
making that video and I thank you for
watching that video but after examining
the film for those two months yes two
months examining a film I realized this
film is profound this has to be a film
that's important this is a film that I
think years from now once people examine
it more is going to be a very special
film that a lot of people are going to
remember as a film that challenged its
audience and that's one of the things I
loved about enemy Jake Gyllenhaal was
fantastic he continues to impress me in
every single movie he's done the past
few years and it's strange Bendi
altering story was just fascinating to
me now on the opposite side of that
spectrum we had a lot of films this year
that were just flat-out entertaining and
very well made coming in at number 11 we
have guardians of the galaxy blew me
away it was such an entertaining movie
it was so funny it was so relatable it
was like The Avengers light except just
as entertaining with so many great
characters and really well filmed action
and the soundtrack and the dialogue
everything about the tone of this movie
was such a deviation from Marvel's
previous entertainment while at the same
time keeping what matters about the
Marvel experience the fun adventure I
loved it
let's stay in the Marvel world to talk
about my pick for number 10 Captain
America the Winter Soldier I thought was
a fantastic spy espionage thriller a
movie that went beyond Marvel's general
well we just have to be fun this movie
was dark you actually felt some
consequences in this movie it didn't
feel like everything was going to be
okay there were moments in this movie
where I thought Captain America could
maybe die like it it was very serious at
times and the Winter Soldier was an
awesome villain portrayed excellently by
Sebastian Stan I loved the action in
this film I cannot wait to see Civil War
coming in at number nine is the film I
have seen most recently on this list and
that is
the imitation game with Benedict
Cumberbatch is a film that really
touched me it had a very heartfelt story
a realistic story about a man trying to
break this Nazi code but it was also
about a man who was gay living in a time
in which that was literally illegal and
he could be killed or imprisoned or even
chemically castrated for being that way
I mean what kind of is that but
that happened back in the day imitation
game is a movie that affected me deeply
it got under my skin it got into my
heart but it's also a great spy drama
thriller about some really brave people
back in the day coming in at number
eight was one of my most anticipated
films of this year and that is as the
director David Fincher continues to be
frickin awesome it is difficult to find
a flaw in the way his films are directed
they look wonderful and they're filled
with actors who know what they're doing
Affleck was the perfect choice for this
role because he was able to inhabit a
person who understands what it's like to
be hounded by the media and Rosamund
Pike gave one of the best performances
of the entire year as his wife I don't
want to say anything else about the plot
because it is a film that is best
experienced without knowing anything
definitely see gone girl at number seven
is a movie that I heard whisperings
about for quite some time before I
finally had the opportunity to see Chris
Evans second appearance on this list is
snowpiercer a movie that is so so not
American this is a foreign movie in so
many different ways it's directed by a
Korean man it's a movie that for a long
time feels like this really great sci-fi
action movie and towards the end it just
pulls the rug out from underneath you
and you realize there is an amazing
emotional undercurrent to this movie
that has been there from the beginning
and you didn't even pick up on it if you
guys have not had a chance to see
snowpiercer I implore you to go seek it
out
it was one of the coolest experiences I
had at the movies this year coming in at
number six is a movie that might
surprise you that it's on this list but
this is my list it's a movie that I saw
multiple times and that continuously got
better each time and that movie is
interstellar is a movie that I gave a B+
to and it's a movie that I have flaws
with and it's a movie that I still have
flaws with the flaws that I said in my
original review I still have the simple
fact of the matter is no other film this
year kept making me want to go back to
the theater to see it I've seen this
movie in theaters multiple times now
it's a movie that I want to see still in
theaters and that is saying something do
I still have some of the flaws I had the
first time I saw it yes I do but it is a
film experience that keeps drawing me
back to the theater and the third time I
saw this movie I did cry unlike I did
the first time and I don't know why that
is
but something about this movie for me
got better each time coming in at number
5 we have one of the best character
studies of the entire year
Jake Gyllenhaal is still my pick for
best actor of the year in Nightcrawler
he knocked it so far out of the park
that it flew over the street and then it
landed in my backyard and I picked it up
and I said Wow Jake Gyllenhaal really
really did well that was a stupid
analogy and yes his performance was
great but the writing and the directing
was so strong as well it was a character
that was so loathsome that you really
could see hating but you loved watching
what he was doing and he holds the
camera over his face like that all right
guys we're coming down to the
nitty-gritty here coming in to number
four was one of the biggest surprises of
the year and a very welcome one edge of
tomorrow was awesome this movie was so
much better than everyone thought it was
going to be and it did not make enough
money I bought the steelbook version of
this at Target as well as the other
version because I'm a nerd like that I
like how it actually has edge of
tomorrow really big on the cover cuz
that's the title okay that's what it's
called okay
good this is a sci-fi action movie
filled with dark humor it was so much
better than it could have been it was so
much better than it should have been
this movie was awesome the action was
fantastic and Emily Blunt was so good in
this movie as this badass chick she was
awesome and Tom Cruise played a coward
unlike all the trailer
that marketed him as his awesome hero
guy he was a coward who abandoned his
men and had to learn how to be a good
man
everything about Edgar tomorrow was so
much fun to watch and the ending was
ballsy edge of tomorrow
check it out if you haven't seen it yet
coming in at number three was for me by
far the most surprising movie of this
entire year the babadook is an
Australian film directed by Jennifer
Kent a first-time director and this is
one of the best directed movies of the
year it's one of the scariest movies
I've ever seen in my life and it is one
of the most deeply affecting films I've
ever seen not a monster movie do not go
into this film expecting a horror film
that's a monster movie what this movie
is is a very dark look at depression and
grief and is told in the vein of a
horror film and se Davis is still to
this day my favorite actress performance
of this year she did such a great job in
this film the babadook check it out if
you haven't seen it definitely coming in
at number 2 by far is my favorite ending
of this year when I saw this film when
it ended I almost literally stood up and
cheered I wanted to do that cliched
thing that critics say you will cheer
blah blah blah you never cheer I wanted
to cheer at the end of I've seen
whiplash twice in theaters now and I
want to see it a third time before it
goes out I adored this film the back and
forth and the psychological warfare that
goes on between miles teller and JK
Simmons was such a high note in regards
to acting this year that it just blew me
away the writing and the directing and
especially the finale holy crap the
finale one of the best endings I've ever
seen in my life if you have not seen
whiplash you are doing yourself a
disservice see it well guys you may have
guessed what my number one pick of the
year is but nevertheless my number one
film of 2014 is
there is not a film that I have seen
this year that I can call an experience
except for Birdman from the first scene
to the last scene I was absolutely
transfixed on the screen there was not a
moment of this film that dragged for me
there was not a moment of Birdman that I
felt like well I will check my watch and
see what time it is
it was absolutely euphoric now I
understand if you thought the movie was
overrated or if he didn't like it
because I thought movies are overrated
that I didn't like to other people like
and that's cool but it is the film this
year that just had me invigorated with
the idea of filmmaking again I loved how
they made it all look like one tracking
shot Michael Keaton's performance Edward
Norton Emma Stone Naomi Watts everyone
in this movie Zach Galifianakis oh man
was he good and one of the things I
learned about this movie that was so
funny to me was the actors began to
jokingly keep a tally of how many people
made mistakes Emma Stone apparently made
the worst and Zach Galifianakis
apparently made the least which makes
sense because he's a stand-up comic and
he's used to memorizing a lot of lines I
found that pretty awesome and I love
this movie I really hope you guys do get
a chance to see it whenever it comes out
on blu-ray or if it's in a theater near
you it is my favorite movie of the year
it's the movie that I can truly say was
an experience to be had in the movies
guys 2014 is over you guys are the best
I love you thank you so much for
watching my videos I am truly thankful I
hit 200,000 subscribers recently that is
something I can't even imagine my worst
of the year is coming soon that's a very
different type of video and a very fun
type of video to make I hope you guys
enjoy that it should be released
extremely soon probably within the next
12 hours or so so look forward to that
guys and as always thank you so much for
watching this year and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
you